et maintenant évoquons le dernier
pirates sur internet qui avait la
semaine dernière infecté plus de 6
millions d'ordinateurs dans le monde
c'était un allemand âgé à peine de 18
ans est les grandes sociétés
informatiques comme microsoft en ont
assez de ces piratages alors elles
promettent désormais une récompense à
ceux qui dénonceront les pirates c'est
une forme de délation considère certains
internautes
reportage dans un cybercafé à paris
frédéric monteil tôt et le compte il
était une fois sur le web des
récompenses pour faire tomber les têtes
des pirates
l'itie 10000 livres pour tous
renseignements là dix mille dollars et
jusqu'à 250 mille dollars offerts par
microsoft comme au temps du far west ces
primes attire les délateurs
l'auteur du virus à serre a été dénoncée
en allemagne par des appels
téléphoniques et si la récompense peut
paraître disproportionnée
les dégâts sont énormes durant les trois
premiers jours microsoft a reçu
cinquante mille appels de victimes
en plus la compagnie delta airlines dû
annuler des vols
il est difficile de chiffrer le manque à
gagner je pense qu'il y aura plus d'un
million d'euros de dégâts
offrir de l'argent pour dénoncer un
pirate
l'idée divise la communauté des
internautes il y a ceux qui sont prêts à
tout est ce que vous vous seriez prêt
pour 250 mille dollars a dénoncé un
pirate vous pouvez pourquoi pas rêver
neil j'enquête
même si ça ne vous reproche à vos amis
oui vous êtes prêt à dénoncer votre
voisin votre ami oui parce que je pense
que les gens qui créent des des virus
sont des terroristes
c'est du terrorisme et en plus qui n'a
pas de cause politique
on aurait dit que rien et ces gens là
mais une pagaille totale mais il y a
aussi les puristes ce que l'argent
n'intéresse pas même pour des 150 milles
de là ça n'a rien avant autre solution
gagner de l'argent mais sans dénoncer
c'est ce que propose une association
d'informaticiens leur but propagé sur le
web des leurs à l'heure principalement
qu'elle cesse et nous télécharger un
morceau musée qu'on les écoute à la fin
on est assez content parce qu'on a ce
qu'on veut
puis en réalité où normalement il va y
avoir un message d'avertissement pour
chaque fichier leur distribuer raid spam
promet une rétribution financière
de plus en plus c'est l'argent qui fait
la loi sur le web